[Applause]
hi everyone I'm so excited here today
what a beautiful day to liberate
ourselves from student debt what a
beautiful day to liberate our future
generations from the scourge of
for-profit education and by that we also
means for-profit student loan debt as
well and this is so this is such an
important issue because this is not just
about our future generations in our
current generations but this is about
our entire economy we are experiencing a
systemic and economy-wide threat to
grinding to grinding our economy to a
halt because families and people in my
generation older and younger are not
buying cars were not purchasing homes we
are not building families because of the
sector that student loan debt represents
on our generation it is unjust and it is
a burden that no generation before had
to encounter to the scale and the level
that ours has I think so much about this
moment when I was in college and I was
mentoring this girl that was young woman
her name was I'm today a she was about
three or four years younger than me but
I was about nineteen years old and she
was in high school
and she had gotten into all of these
prestigious universities but she was
given no student loan assistance no real
student she was given no scholarships
all of her student aid was presented to
her in the form of loans and she came
from a solid middle-class family she was
not exceedingly wealthy and and so she
really she got into her cream dream
college but her dream College offered
her no scholarships just loans and she
truly felt at sixteen seventeen years
old
she felt that the decision of college
was so important that she felt that she
needed to consider taking on two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars worth of debt
to go to college
and she's 17 years old and Here I am
calling her from my dormitory a 19 year
old consulting a 17 year old about a 250
thousand dollar loan debt situation and
I think that in and of itself
illustrates the absurdity of our
education financing system that alone
illustrates it because what we tell
seventeen year olds all the time is that
you are not old enough or responsible
enough to drink
you are not old enough or responsible
enough to vote you are not old enough or
responsible enough to serve in our
military but you are old enough and
responsible enough to take on a quarter
million dollars worth of debt and that
is wrong it is not right not only is
that what we are telling children now
minors now but that's what we have told
them for decades and it has resulted in
a crisis that we have seen today now
people are in their 30s and and older
that have taken on insurmountable
amounts of debt because we have sold
them an empty bill of goods and what we
need to do is make it right and that is
why we have to both make public colleges
tuition free and forgive all student
loan debt at the same time and and I
will be completely honest I will
disclose my my personal stake in this
fight because I have student loans too
and I think it's so funny a year ago I
was waiting tables in a restaurant and
it was literally easier for me to become
the youngest woman and American history
elected to Congress and it means to pay
off my student loan debt so that should
tell you everything about the state of
this
and this of our economy and the state of
quality of life for working people
because in order for me to get a chance
to have health care in order for me to
get a chance to pay off my student loans
I had to do something that was nearly
impossible and I don't think that that
is the bar through which a person should
be able to access education healthcare
and a bevy of other things that should
be considered human rights and this bill
and I'm so excited to be introducing
this bill with senator Sanders
congresswoman a towbar and congresswoman
Jaya Paul to make sure that we start in
embarking on the solutions to these
problems thank you very much
[Applause]